joining us now is Helen Shaman the first
British astronaut to travel into space
hi it's great to see how excited are you
oh this is just tremendous isn't it and
we've been of course a big build up we
are so hopeful at the end of the summer
and it got scrubbed um and then it we
were hoping again um in early October no
no go but yeah now now we've actually
you know we've had that amazing launch
and the the Society of the rocket namely
didn't go again apparently they fixed it
with a spanner in the last minute I mean
we was quite incredible isn't it and
we've got there's a whole load of
technology and of course there's I mean
isn't that 489 different criteria um for
go or no-go and that didn't include a
valve that didn't quite you know wasn't
wasn't quite tight enough and I guess
it's the temperature that changes that
tends to open these things but yes the
the the technicians who actually made
that happen and all hats off to them and
the teamwork that went with it why do we
want to go to the Moon oh I mean I
suppose we will talk about going back to
the Moon because yes we've been before
haven't we the moon will allow us to
find out an awful lot more about not
only our own planet
um it will allow us to find out more
about what we need to do to go to Mars
and it'll open up what we're hoping to
be as a lunar economy as well so um
materials that we can't make anywhere
else that we can produce on the moon
partly to use in space that we might use
let's say for satellites to be able to
beam energy clean energy back down to us
on Earth or perhaps it's just materials
that we can use on Earth in in other
Industries so there's a whole load of
different reasons to go different
spin-offs but I think the main thing is
really it's on the way to going to Mars
why is it taking us so long oh
I think to be quite honest right now
it's a it's a really hot time
politically it it we could have done it
sooner if we wanted to but it is
expensive and we've got lots of
different priorities and pools on money
yes we need education we need our
Healthcare we've got global economy
that's been up and down and there's so
many things going on but um but in the
end it's been decided that because of
China and the the Chinese desire to
return to go to the Moon they haven't
been yet
um but um there's this race to get
particularly to the South Pole where
there might be ice and other important
minerals clearly rare Earths so um yeah
there is now a political reason to go to
the moon now rather than 10 years ago
would you like to go oh I'd love to go I
think um yeah I can't imagine there's an
astronaut who would say they would not
want to go to the Moon Yeah and um and
of course then ultimately to Mars that's
got to be the real big ticket
destination yeah of course you were the
first Brit in space weren't you what was
that like oh tremendous I mean I thought
that of course a big sense of
responsibility because I applied to go
into space because I thought it would be
good for me I thought it would be fun if
I'm quite honest and interesting doing
things that you can't do on Earth
um it was only as the time got a bit
closer I realized actually there's a bit
of a bit of responsibility here because
I'm not just doing it for me this is the
first British space flight and and I had
some form of responsibility I suppose to
um to communicate what was going on
about it or had happened after I came
back but also subsequently really um a
lot of teachers tell me that I've been a
bit of a role model for some of the
students and so which is lovely and very
flattering but yes it does give me a bit
of a the sense of a keen sense of
responsibility to make sure that I live
up to that do you think you'll find
yourself in a position where you could
go to the Moon still one should never
say no I never thought I would go into
space the first time it's um it was for
me it was a complete one-off
um nobody from Britain had been before
so why why would I even think when I was
growing up that it could happen to me so
no it wasn't it wasn't on the agenda
then it's not on my agenda now but you
know we should never say no to be quite
honest probably I would give that
opportunity to somebody who was younger
and who might manage to then have a
whole career of being an astronaut and
and doing many more useful things in
their lifetime but I wouldn't turn down
the opportunity if it was handed to me
on a plane there we go so when do you
think we'll find ourselves on the moon
again and when do you think we'll be in
on Mars oh well actually people walking
on the moon and NASA said two years I
think it'll slip to three Mars
20 years if I'm going to be you'll be a
little bit Brave 25 if I'm being
conservative yeah but it's it's you know
it's in most of our lifetimes yes and we
can really look forward to that and you
know I just think it's a time now when
we're hearing so much about people who
are self-serving or being destructive
it's so inspirational to see what we can
do when we cooperate positively towards
something that could benefit humankind
in general it's absolute pleasure to
have met you thank you so much for
joining us thanks a lot thank you
um obviously we'll keep an eye on that
Artemis I think I'm writing saying was
the twin of Apollo Apollo there we go uh
Greek goddess of hunting
something like that yeah
we're gonna go with that we'll be on a
Trivial Pursuit team together it's good
to talk to you thanks so much Lindy